dug in behind their barricades they're
preparing for the worst keith has turned
into a fortress and everyone has joined
the fight
men who just two weeks ago said in
offices or worked as builders are now
defending their country's capital
for yuri malinsky this war has become
very personal his youngest brother was
killed by russian rockets just three
days ago
i recognized my brother only from his
clothes there was no other way of
recognizing him
a former air force officer he left his
job as a truck driver in the netherlands
to fight against the russians
here are guys who never went to war who
never fired a shot who never even heard
the sound of a rifle but we are all
ready trust me my morale has never been
this high and i've never been this ready
and this is what is moving towards them
less than 15 kilometers away these
images show the russian column that was
around 60 kilometers long has dispersed
around the capital possibly preparing
for a full-out attack soon we can hear
the sound of challenge coming closer to
the city putting the capital's defense
on its highest alert with russian forces
coming closer tensions are going up by
the hour but these civil defenders are
confident they'll stop them
a battle for the future of kiev the main
target in putin's war those who remain
in the city are bracing themselves for
his bombs and missiles the threat of
more death and destruction has brought
people together alina kimlach helps the
elderly and sick who can't leave their
apartments to get food or are simply too
afraid to go out
ninety-five-year-old ala saficina who
has seen more than enough war in her
life
what is the point for me to leave at my
age especially if you see how i walk i
had two surgeries i broke my hip i have
not been to the street for 10 years my
knees wanted to take me for a walk but i
told them i want to die in my bed
we have shelter down
she can go and like if it will be some
bombs or wreckage she can't even left
her apartment so maybe people who can
walk at least we told them you can need
to go downstairs you can go to the
shelter but about here
i don't know
alina can't decide if you should leave
kiev with her eight-month-old daughter
and go on a long and unpredictable
journey but the constant shelling and
sirens are making her very nervous
she can only hope the ukrainian defense
will halt
when the battle begins we'll be afraid
but i know that fear will crumble very
quickly
they're fighting for their land their
country and most of all for their lives
and those of their children and
grandchildren step faster al jazeera
kiev